[Musique]
journée de 8h démocratie directe
retraite à 60 ans Bourse du travail
droit de grève écologique droit des
femmes contraceptiques avortement congés
payés sécurité sociale et éducation
populaire
l'anarchisme qui avait fini par montrer
son vrai visage au grand soleil
d'Espagne entre avec la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale dans une longue
nuit peuplée de monstres
dans l'euphorique de la victoire on
oublie les pactes les passivités les
collaborations plus ou moins actives et
on les cherche des anarchistes de
l'histoire
décimés isolés et oubliés incapable de
reprendre le combat sur le front social
les libertaires choisissent alors de
s'engager dans la bataille culturelle il
s'invente des symboles recréer des
solidarités et investissent de nouveaux
champs de lutte et dans le cours de la
guerre froide ils sont bientôt rejoints
par une jeunesse neuve qui tout en
donnant de l'anarchisme une autre image
contribue à lui offrir une nouvelle
visibilité mais ces nouveaux révoltés
qui rêvent de paix et prônent l'amour
avec pour seuls armes des fleurs ou bien
des pavés se heurte partout au pouvoir
et c'est ainsi qu'à l'Est comme à
l'Ouest et d'une au sud l'anarchisme
préoccupe petit à petit le devant de la
scène il souffle ses idées
anti-autoritaires depuis la coulisse du
mouvement pacifiste il inspire les
nouvelles formes de la contestation et
imprégnant fin de son esprit libertaire
un mouvement insurrectionnel qui aurait
pu changer la face du monde
c'est derrière les fils de fer barbelés
dans l'odeur âcre du crématoire
[Musique]
et sous le regard insolent de mettre qui
croit qu'ils sont des dieux que la
seconde partie du 20e siècle commence
aussi pour les anarchistes
ou comme des dizaines de milliers
d'autres prisonniers politiques les
anarchistes arrêtés par la Gestapo ou
livrée par la police de Vichy laissèrent
leur peau
quand vient l'heure de la libération
bien que les antifascistes saluent en
espagnol les forces alliés les quelques
libertaires qui ont survécu à la guerre
ne peuvent que constater que le
mouvement anarchiste s'est en Europe à
réduit comme le pot de chagrin et qu'il
a perdu presque toute son influence
il se replie sur lui-même
et au lendemain de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale les anarchistes ne représentent
plus qu'un mouvement minoritaire qui
nous fait que ressasser ces vieilles
idées sa mythologie
en tournant en rond sans avoir pu aucune
influence sur les mouvements sociaux
on peut dire qu'après l'échec de la
révolution espagnole et la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
l'anarchisme entre vraiment dans une
longue nuit
[Musique]
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale il
devient très difficile d'être anarchiste
que ce soit en Europe en Amérique du
Nord ou en Asie
parce que le monde est divisé en deux
camps
ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre il ne
soutiennent aucun des deux camps pendant
la guerre froide et cela les exclu de la
scène politique mondiale
on se sent très seul quand on est
anarchiste pendant cette période
au lendemain de la guerre les
anarchistes ne choisissent effectivement
pas leur camp mais il recréer un peu
partout les organisations
la Fédération des socialistes
libertaires allemandes et les
fédérations anarchistes françaises et
italienne chocoforme de la fin des
combats au nord l'organisation centrale
des travailleurs de Suède devient le
bastion libertaire le plus fort d'Europe
et au sud tandis que les exils les
Espagnols ouvrent une CNT à Paris des
groupes de résistance formés notamment
par Kiko sabatés qui attaque ici au
mortier reprennent sur la péninsule le
combat contre la dictature franquiste
même à l'Est on voit renaître un courant
libertaire comme en Bulgarie ou la
Fédération des anarchos communistes
organisent son congrès et rédigent une
nouvelle plateforme
l'Amérique latine n'est pas en reste qui
voit les anarchistes se regrouper par
exemple au Chili et à Cuba au sein de
grandes fédérations syndicalistes
révolutionnaires tandis que l'Afrique a
perdu momentanément toutes les
structures la toute jeune fédération
anarchiste japonaise emmenée par
Ishikawa son Shiro et la Fédération des
bâtisseurs d'une société libre créée en
1945 par les frères Lio cue et lion cue
surnommé des robots coréen témoignent
quant à elle de la survivance de
l'anarchisme en Asie mais c'est en
dehors des organisations et grâce à l'un
de ses courants méconnus que
l'anarchisme commence dans cette longue
nuit de la pragaire à revenir un peu
dans la lumière
ce qui se passe pour l'anarchisme c'est
que l'idée selon laquelle la guerre
serait la santé des états
devient le cœur de la pensée libertaire
à cause de la deuxième guerre mondiale
que l'État est directement lié au
fascisme à la guerre aux chaînes de
commandement et au dommage collatéraux
le pacifisme libertaire ou anarchisme
non violent qui vient d'une longue
tradition connaître avec le début de la
guerre froide un véritable regain
héritier de la Boétie chalet Soro et
Tolstoï c'est partisans eux aussi
radicalement changé le monde mais il
pense à l'inverse des apôtres de
l'insurrection armée qui des possibles
et même nécessaire de le faire sans
violence
[Musique]
c'est un argument que développe de
nombreux penseurs de premier plan et qui
se fondent sur l'attention particulière
que les anarchistes accordent à
l'adéquation entre les moyens et les
fins
les moyens que vous employez pour
provoquer le changement social doivent
s'accorder avec l'objectif que vous
voulez atteindre
sinon se place dans ce cadre le recours
à la violence entre souvent en
contradiction avec vos objectifs
en effet si vous voulez construire une
société basée sur la coopération sur le
consensus la démocratie directe sur la
discussion
alors la violence politique n'est pas le
moyen à utiliser pour atteindre ce but
il y a même de fortes chances pour
qu'elle nuise à votre projet
inspire d'autant plus les
révolutionnaires à l'époque que pour la
fois la non-violence semble avoir prouvé
en Inde dans les faits sans l'efficacité
mais alors que la guerre froide
s'intensifie c'est face à l'émergence
d'une nouvelle menace à la fois globale
et mortelle que les pacifistes
libertaires peuvent commencer à se faire
connaître et diffuser plus largement
leurs pensées
ça change fondamentalement l'état
d'esprit non seulement des anarchistes
mais de toutes les personnes critiques
des pouvoirs établies parce que ça
marque l'imagination
l'idée de cette perpétuelle menace de
mort qui plane cette bombe qui peut
exploser à tout moment ça a poussé les
gens vers les mouvements pacifistes
la population s'est mise à demander la
paix de manière passionnée
contre la prolifération atomique des
mouvements antimilitaristes et
pacifistes et closes alors dans le monde
entier on se souvient par exemple en
France du mouvement pour la paix et de
celui des citoyens du monde de carie
Davis mais il y a aussi le banc de bon
mouvement qui s'étend d'Angleterre
acides et il y aura bientôt les
gigantesques mobilisation contre la
guerre au Vietnam certains sont
d'ailleurs impulsés directement par les
libertaires comme le Vietnam day comédie
que fondera Jerry Robbins où le
mouvement pour les objecteurs de
conscience animé en France par Louis
Lecoin mais s'il est vrai que presque
tous les anarchistes sont alors
pacifistes tous les pacifistes ne sont
pas pour autant anarchiste on retrouve
dans ces mobilisation des humanistes
libéraux des chrétiens progressistes des
socialistes plus ou moins radicaux et
toute une flopée de militants sans idée
politique arrêtée qui souhaite au juste
avoir la paix
en mettant en oeuvre une sorte de
stratégie de Goku les libertaires n'en
décide pas moins de les rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas nouveau les anarchistes de
la fin du 19e siècle faisait exactement
la même chose il ne crée pas de grandes
organisations de masse il essayait même
pas de convaincre les gens de devenir un
archiste qu'ils essayent de faire
c'était de radicaliser les gens afin
qu'ils décident de prendre leurs
affaires en main il diffusaient leurs
idées et les gens sanarchisaient et les
anarchistes de l'après-guerre font
exactement la même chose ça va filant
qu'ils essayent de faire dans ces
mouvements c'est de convaincre les gens
qu'on ne peut pas avoir l'état sans la
bombe si vous ne voulez pas de la bombe
vous devez vous débarrasser de l'État
c'est l'argument principal qu'il met en
avant
et ce qui est vraiment intéressant à ce
sujet c'est que les vieux courants
pacifistes ont commencé à dénoncer ce
lien également
et grâce à ça on a vu naître des
relations très fortes entre les groupes
pacifistes et les groupes anarchistes
cette Royaume-Uni ou à la différence des
autres pays européens le mouvement pour
la peine est pas contrôlé dans sous-main
par Moscou que les liens entre
anarchiste et pacifiste deviennent les
plus solides et les plus étroits dans la
campagne pour le désarmement nucléaire
derrière Bertrand Roussel qui en est la
figure de proue on retrouve en effet
toute la crème de l'anarchisme
britannique comme herbertrid est-elle
Magnan Alex comfort ou kalinware et leur
influence se fait rapidement ressentir
jusque dans le nom que je donne le
mouvement et qui dit presque tout
le Comité d'action direct n'était pas
seulement un mouvement contre la guerre
il développait aussi une véritable
critique sociale basée sur les travaux
des anarchistes
d'action direct en témoigne
c'est une traduction directe de la
pensée anarchiste
l'idée qui peut paraître en réalité très
radicale et très conflictuelle
c'est de changer les choses vous-même
plutôt que de demander à quelqu'un
d'autre de le faire
mais au contact des pacifices les
anarchistes découvrent à leur tour de
nouvelles techniques de Luc qu'il décide
d'adopter tant que le sang illustré le
message libertaire
de pas se festin c'est vous de ce pays
les tactiques pacifistes comme la
désobéissance civile ou les sittines par
exemple mettent en lumière la violence
de l'État en
usant de violence contre des
manifestants non violents l'État en
quelque sorte ce condamne lui-même de
conceptes
convaincu que c'est un mouvement de
masse qui peut leur donner l'avantage le
17 septembre 1961 un appel élancé pour
une grande manifestation à Trafalgar
Square
mis sous la pression le pouvoir
britannique réactualise le justiciers of
the peace Act une loi vieille de 600 ans
presque jour pour jour qui permet
d'incarrer de manière préventive les
fauteurs de troubles
32 membres du comité sont d'ailleurs
jetés en prison dont Alex confort que
Bertrand Russell alors âgé de 89 ans
le jour J pourtant près de 15000
personnes se rassemblent et font ainsi
teen sur la grande place de Londres
là cette démonstration de force
non-violente une impressionne que la
pellicule des caméras
et déjà des anarchistes s'interrogent
beaucoup d'anarchistes au sein du
mouvement commence à considérer les
tactiques pacifices soit comme très
naïvement
inefficace si l'on pense à la lutte des
classes
pour ne rien faire
[Musique]
nombreux sont de révolutionnaires au
royaume du commaillère à abandonné alors
les tactiques pacifistes et quand par la
suite des anarchistes accepteront le
participer à des manifestations pour la
paix ce sera souvent pour y accroître la
conflictualité mais il faut attendre les
années 60 au pays des fleurs des
nouveaux chevaliers blancs de la
Révolution mettent grâce à une nouvelle
forme de lutte non violente à proprement
parler le feu aux poudres
[Musique]
les sixties dans les pays occidentaux le
monde a bien changé les grands ensembles
ont recouvert les ruines le baby-boom a
rajeunit les populations le plein emploi
remplit les porte-monnaies et le rêve
américain commencer à coloniser les
imaginaires
l'émergence d'une classe moyenne a même
fait oublier l'ancien thévage social on
est entré dans la société des loisirs et
de la consommation c'est de règne des
supermarchés de l'automobile et de la
télévision c'est l'âge d'or du tabac du
rock'n'roll et du soda c'est aussi de
triomphe de l'État-providence qui impose
révolutionnaire d'approfondir leurs
critiques
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale vous
avez un état beaucoup plus présent qui
promet une éducation universelle qui
assure l'aide sociale pour tous qui
réglemente de plus en plus les droits
des travailleurs
l'État semble donc plus bienveillant que
les États d'il y a 100 ou 150 ans les
anarchistes sont donc dans une certaine
mesure le dos au mur car la vie semble
s'être améliorée pour beaucoup de gens
mais ce que les anarchistes essaient de
montrer c'est que cette bonne vie n'est
pas la vie bonne
scouts et l'argument critique des
anarchistes et que le capitalisme et la
culture de masse de la société moderne
vous savez le consumérisme la publicité
l'émergence de Coca-Cola
tout cela incarne une forme de banalité
et diffuse une sorte de culture banale
et stérile
donc ce sentiment absurde et notamment
ressenti par la jeunesse qui a pris peu
à peu conscience de son ombre de sa
force et du rôle moteur qu'elle pourrait
jouer dans un processus révolutionnaire
à l'instar des États-Unis d'Amérique
avec le free space movement elle
commence à faire entendre un peu partout
sa voix en ce début d'année 1965 ce
phénomène va devenir aussi manifeste au
Pays-Bas même si l'anarchisme n'y a pas
encore connu son regain et que la
société semble verrouillée de
l'Intérieur
[Musique]
étriqué
la société était refermée sur elle-même
et les jeunes n'avaient pas leur mot à
dire
dans les années 60
l'autoritarisme ambiant
en philosophique qui décide ici de
sonner l'heure de la révolte roule 22 à
méditer au sein du mouvement bande de
bande néerlandais et attend lui aussi
des limites des tactiques de lutte
pacifiste mais bien qu'il occupe des
hommes une fonction importante au sein
du mensuel anarchiste d'ivray il se
sentent un peu à l'étroit dans les
organisations libertaires
traditionnelles
[Musique]
l'anarchisme des années 60 c'était en
fait des anarchistes des années 20
c'était un groupe de vieux et lui il
était le seul jeune et il avait du mal à
faire avancer ses nouvelles idées ce qui
provoquait beaucoup de querelles et de
disputes
il a donc quitté le mouvement anarchiste
très déçu pour créer son propre
mouvement et son propre magazine
pour lancer son mouvement roulant décide
avec quelques camarades dans l'éditeur
obstol que de créer un journal il
l'intitulé Provo un nom d'autant mieux
choisi quand l'interpellant directement
une partie de la jeunesse qu'il surnomme
provotaria par opposition avec un
prolétariat devenu selon lui incapable
de changer le monde il a le mérite
dénoncer tout un programme
était tiré d'une thèse de criminologie
il définissait une forme de délinquance
et
les Provost ont décidé de l'utiliser de
manière créative pour évoquer la façon
dont on pouvait propager la résistance
et c'était au travers de la provocation
voilà l'idée
donc si vous pouviez transgresser ou
briser les règles ou vous engagez dans
une activité qui allait choquer ou
irriter voir faire enrager le pouvoir et
provoquer une réaction de sa part
vous pourriez attirer des gens dans un
mouvement de résistance
et bien le premier théoriser le fameux
cycle provocation répression
mobilisation dans un tract il en
décortique précisément la mécanique et
en affiche ouvertement les objectifs
la provocation dans les circonstances
actuelles est devenu notre seul arme par
la provocation nous pouvons démasquer
l'autorité uniforme botte képi sabre
chien policier gaz lacrymogène il faut
la forcer à utiliser contre nous tous
ces moyens de répression elle sera alors
contrainte de montrer sa vraie nature
elle deviendra de plus en plus
impopulaire et l'opinion publique
basculera en faveur de l'anarchie
comme leur texte nous sentirait qu'à
quelques centaines d'exemplaires pour
mettre toutes les chances de leur côté
les pauvres ressortent les vieux
épouvantails ils impriment une recette
pour fabriquer des bons
[Musique]
dans la ville
il y a des arrestations
[Musique]
et donc ça mobilise
parce que ça fait exactement ce que vous
avez pour but de faire c'est à dire
provoquer
en quelques mois le groupe passe d'une
vingtaine de membres à plusieurs
centaines mais s'ils arrivent à fédérer
plus largement c'est aussi parce que les
propos ne font pas que provoquer c'est
partisans de l'action directe de la
propagande par le fait font les
propositions et MEXT stand œuvre leurs
idées afin de lutter contre la
domination automobile par exemple ils
inventent le plan vélo blanc et mettent
des bicyclettes gratuites et en libre
accès dans les rues d'Amsterdam ils font
les happening manifestent contre les
colonialismes anciens et nouveaux et
imagine des alternatives crédibles aux
dérives de la société de consommation
alors mesure et avec leur faible moyen
mais toujours sans violence les Provos
essaient donc de changer le monde en le
repeignante avec cette couleur blanche
qui devient ainsi au cœur des années 60
au Pays-Bas le nouveau noir des
anarchistes mais le maire d'Amsterdam
guysman
le chef de la police considère que cette
agitation non pas comme de la
provocation mais comme de véritables
menaces ils empêchent les happening ils
font confisquer les vélos les provosts
les inquiettes d'autant plus quand ce
mois de mars 1966 à Amsterdam doit
accueillir un événement de la plus haute
importance or une fois n'est pas coutume
les provocateurs pourraient se sentir
provoqués et décider de passer à
l'action
[Musique]
on apprend dans les journaux que la
princesse héritière venait de se fiancer
avec un Allemand
qui avait été membre de la jeunesse
hitléienne et qui avait participé à la
guerre comme soldat dans la Wehrmacht
il était donc considéré par la gauche
comme un véritable nazi
et dans le contexte de l'Holocauste et
la façon dont il s'était déroulé
particulièrement au Pays-Bas et
Amsterdam c'était vraiment vraiment
problématique
afin de manifester l'Europe audition à
cette union qui aura lieu le 10 mars et
sera retransmis dans l'Eurovision les
promos souhaitent s'inviter à la noce et
comme roule 22 n'avait aussi théorisé
qui n'était qu'une image figuré en bonne
place sur la photo de mariage pour faire
monter la pression en amont des noces il
s'amuse à faire courir les plus folles
rumeurs
[Musique]
non pas avec de la violence mais avec
des propositions loufoques
ils avaient dit par exemple qu'ils
allaient mettre du LSD dans l'eau
potable d'Amsterdam ou sur des morceaux
de sucre pour les donner aux chevaux de
la police
le LSD était la drogue en vogue à ce
moment là et on l'a d'ailleurs aussitôt
interdit
tout cela a créé une sorte de panique
réaction
une présence policière massive
[Musique]
au matin du 10 mars 1966 cette très
forte présence policière du dissuader
les proposer car au début tout semble
bien se passer le carrosse royal centre
tranquillement la foule et remonte au
pas sous l'oeil borgne des caméras du
monde entier la place d'une dame vers la
Western
malgré le gris du ciel et du noir et
blanc pour les millions de
téléspectateurs qui regardent la
cérémonie la Hollande a décidément pas
usurpé sa réputation de pays où il ne se
passe jamais rien la mariée est bien
belle le protocole fastueux et l'ordre
assuré mais tout à coup c'est la Cohu le
désordre la confusion
le terrorisme aurait-il à nouveau frappé
sur le passage de tête couronné
pour la première fois depuis des
dizaines d'années des bombes ont explosé
des bombes
c'était une bombe fumigène
juste de la fumée
depuis quelques temps les provosts
pendant des nuits entières dans un petit
appartement clandestin ils avaient
minusculeusement mélangé les trois
volumes de nitrate de potassium avec les
deux volumes de sucre glace et fabriquer
un cycle de 200 bombes fumigènes qui
n'ont besoin que d'une allumette ou d'un
mégot pour partir en fumée un arsenal
inoffensif certes mais elle est fait de
souffle dévastateurs
on le fait partir en fumée
on enfume tout c'est de l'enfumage
c'est évidemment un geste théâtre
et à tout se fasse et les autorités se
sont sentis ridiculisées ce qui les a
mis en colère
et c'est ce qui explique pourquoi la
répression par la suite a été si sévère
chez le journal le télégraphe n'exige
pas vraiment la solution finale de la
question Provo le chef de la police lui
demande bien la tête des meneurs
[Musique]
la maréchaussée arpente la ville avec
des mégaformes toute manifestation est
interdite le moindre a trop piment est
violemment dispersé dans les rues
d'Amsterdam la chasse aux Provost est
ouverte
la répression frappe
[Musique]
une chose était en train de changer
la population commençait à avoir de la
sympathie pour les Provos
que de plus en plus de gens défendaient
leurs actions et condamnaient l'attitude
des autorités
au milieu de l'année 1966 malgré l'arrêt
pression ou plutôt grâce à elle les
Provost sont au fait de leur gloire leur
nom réserve leurs idées voyages et ils
font des petits au Pays-Bas bien sûr ont
des groupes se constituent à Rotterdam
là ou Maastricht mais aussi dans toute
l'Europe en Belgique en Suisse en
Allemagne de l'Ouest en Italie le à
Paris ou une manifestation a lieu au cri
d'anarchie et liberté et le péril blanc
s'étend jusqu'aux États-Unis d'Amérique
où le constaté touchant un parc de
Berkley et renommée provoque en hommage
aux révolutionnaires
le monde entier a les yeux tournés vers
la Hollande et certains imaginent déjà
que la révolte Jeanne ludique et
libertaire des Provost pourraient se
transformer en révolution
un mouvement social qui commence alors
il va mener les Pays Bas au bord de
l'insurrection semble leur donner raison
le 13 juin à l'appel des organisations
syndicales une grande mobilisation des
travailleurs a lieu roulent 22 et ses
camarades appellent le provoteuria à se
joindre à la manifestation
la mort accidentale d'un manifestants
dont la rumeur dit qu'il a été victime
de violence policière fait soudain
converger l'éluques
la manifestation tourne à l'émeuble les
Provost et les travailleurs rejoint par
la masse des étudiants et les blousons
noirs transforme le centre-ville en
champ du bataille on décède les pavés on
retourne les voitures malgré le soutien
des proxénètes la police et lapidée le
journal le télégraphe est incendié
Amsterdam s'enflamme
devant l'ampleur des troubles le
Parlement est convoqué en
s'extraordinaire
résultat le commissaire de police a été
démi et le maire d'Amsterdam a dû
démissionner
cela aurait pu être une victoire pour
les pros mais pris dans leur logique non
violente au lieu de pousser leur
avantage ceci préfère se dissocier du
mouvement en évoquant une hystérie
collective avec laquelle il n'avait rien
à voir
incapable de saisir ce momentum
révolutionnaire la fin de leur mouvement
n'est plus qu'une longue à goniche
infiltrée leur plan sont éventés et
comme les nouvelles autorités savent ne
peut réagir en provocation leur tactique
tour la vie alors comme ceux qui vivent
du spectacle périssent souvent par le
spectacle eux qui n'avaient voulu être
que des images connaissent le destin des
images ils deviennent des cartes
postales
qui venait non seulement de la presse
mais également de la jeunesse qui
arrivait de partout ont proposé même des
provoquours
tout cela dépassait l'intention
originelle de ces garçons
c'était juste un club de rebelle au
départ
dans un dernier sursaut roule 22 mais
c'est camarades de dissoudre le
mouvement le 15 mai 1967 il se
réunissent dans le coin des orateurs du
Vandel Park et annonce la fin du
mouvement Provost
[Musique]
et voilà c'était la fin après deux ans
pendant lesquelles ils ont mis les
Pays-Bas sans dessus dessous les Provost
sont alors partis chacun de leur côté
[Musique]
ne confiera plus tard à propos de
l'échec du mouvement Provo notre seule
erreur est d'avoir visé trop court la
geste des problèmes Amsterdam est
aujourd'hui relativement tombée dans
l'oubli elle aura cependant une
influence décisive dans les années
suivantes par inspiré par leurs idées et
leur stratégie mais aussi conscients des
limites de leurs mouvements d'autres
libertaires vont reprendre leur flambeau
et faire en 1968 l'espace d'un printemps
bourgeonné toutes les espérances
révolutionnaires
[Musique]
bonne nuit faites de beaux rêves
à la veille de l'année 68 le mouvement
anarchiste en France n'est toujours pas
sorti de la nuit
[Musique]
il faut voir que fatalité gros plus que
l'air ici comme partout d'ailleurs les
organisations libertaires ne cessent
pendant ces années de ce scinder
fusionner disparaître puis renaître
[Musique]
pour rassembler tous ces groupes
coordonnées leurs activités et tisser
des liens avec d'autres cellules
révolutionnaires on le trouve pas mieux
que de créer des comités à foison
on s'y perd
face à ces organisations des organisées
il devient essentiel de rétablir un
semblant d'unité le groupe des jeunes
libertaires de Paris décide d'inventer
un symbole
l'uncerclé date d'avril 1964
il est présenté disons devant le
mouvement anarchiste dans un numéro du
Bulletin de jeunesse libertaire des
jeunes libertaires et avec une
explication de pourquoi
il serait bon que les anarchistes quand
ils font des inscriptions sur les murs
quand ils font des affiches mettent ce
symbole de façon systématique
de motivation principale nous ont guidés
d'abord faciliter et rendre plus
efficace les activités pratiques
d'inscription et d'affichage ensuite
assurer une présence plus large du
mouvement anarchiste aux yeux des gens
le sigle adoptait nous apparut répondre
le mieux à ses critères en l'associant
constamment aux anarchistes il finira
par un automatisme mental bien connu par
évoquer tout seul l'idée de l'anarchisme
dans l'esprit des gens
techniques de marketing finalement c'est
aussi bête que ça si tous les groupes
anarchistes malgré leur
différence très forte disant et des fois
l'opposition qu'il y avait entre
signer mettez un même logo ça veut rien
effet multiplicateur de la présence des
anarchistes sur les murs de Paris ou
dans la vie politique parisienne
l'effet n'est pas immédiat
et alors que le vent de contestation
soufflé par la jeunesse semble charrier
un peu partout un esprit entier
autoritaire et libertaire
en France c'est le calme plat
un grand journal du soir prétend même
que la France s'ennuie
et pourtant tout commence en banlieue
parisienne dans l'université de Nanterre
qui est devenu depuis quelques temps un
bouillon de culture de la contestation
et où l'on compte aussi de nombreux
militants en archiste convaincus et
expérimenté
anarchiste voilà et nous publions ces
trappes qui sont en fait un plagiat dans
notre plagiat car maintenant pour la
meilleure façon de savoir ce que c'est
vous le lisez et puis vous pouvez vous
faire le tracking
vous avez des rapports avec certains
flics non
similitant connaissent leur histoire
libertaire certains sont même allés au
Pays-Bas rencontrer les Provost il
critiquent le système éducatif qui nous
fait selon eux que reproduire les
structures de domination mais ils ne
veulent pas seulement porter la
révolution à l'université ils entendent
globalement changer la vie parmi eux se
fait très tôt remarquer un certain
Daniel Cohn-Bendit que l'on dit alors
libertaire alors là il y a pas photo
là-dessus c'est un militant anarchiste
membre de la Fédération anarchiste
membre de la liaison des étudiants
anarchistes membres de noir et rouge
membres de tous ces mouvements parties
prenantes à part entière mais il n'est
pas le seul et à ses côtés d'autres
figures apparaissent comme Olivier
Castro qui se définit alors comme un
anarchiste indépendant Jean-Pierre
Duteil qui appartient lui aussi à la
liaison des étudiants anarchistes ou le
discret renard diesel toujours avec ses
lunettes noires qui fondera le groupe
des enragés avec une centaine d'autres
étudiants ceci
[Musique]
et pendant plusieurs jours et plusieurs
nuits enivré par l'odeur des gaz de
jeunes révoltés écrivent dans l'air une
ancienne chanson de geste ou improvise
de nouveaux pas dedans
il y a cette griserie extraordinaire qui
ne prend que les émotiers et que tu n'as
pas été me tienne ne peut pas savoir ce
de quoi il s'agit
le goût le goût de la barricade
contrairement à ce que dit la légende la
répression est très brutale
[Musique]
mais rien n'y fait le quartier
d'atteinte tombe aux mains des insurgés
finalement réouverte la Sorbonne est
proclamée comme une libre le drapeau
noir flotte sur la cour d'honneur on
rebaptise des salles du nom des héros de
l'histoire libertaire comme l'ont fit au
nom une assemblée générale permanente et
formée un comité d'occupation révocable
à tout instant a été élu on écrit sur
les murs on réinvente la culture on
imprime des tracts et des journaux on
ouvre une cantine libre et gratuite pour
tous on crée une crèche autogérée grâce
à la redoutable section des combattants
catanais on organise aussi l'autre
défense à tous les étages pendant plus
d'un mois on discute du monde de la vie
de l'amour et de la Révolution
je te dis qu'il faut changer les
structures de la société si on veut
changer l'université
tous les étudiants ne sont pas un
archistes bien sûr loin sans faut mais
les libertaires sont là avec les
militants des autres tendances
révolutionnaires Maui je te trots
avec aussi et surtout la marche des
étudiants dans les idées ne sont pas
encore bien arrêtés mais qui veulent
prendre par eux aussi au mouvement la
grande qualité des anarchistes 2 mai 68
a été de permettre à une ribambelle de
gens que l'on appelait inorganisé des
gens qui venaient de nulle part qui
soudain émergeait en mai 68 de leur
permettre de prendre toute leur place et
non pas de les renvoyer à l'école au
cours primaire qu'il fallait qu'ils
passent tous les échos et ça ça a été
une grande force
libertaire
d'émancipation qui a permis à chacun de
prendre sa place en quelque sorte tout
en luttant beaucoup contre les menées
staliniennes de certains groupuscules
même si c'était pas des staliniens même
s'ils étaient anti stalinien ils avaient
souvent des pratiques
qui était peu recommandable
disons le mouvement faitage d'huile et
comme ici avec l'Université de
Strasbourg il s'étend bientôt à toutes
les universités françaises mais pas que
c'est un moment dans lequel on a souvent
tendance à
surévaluer la composante la composante
étudiante la composante culturelle de la
contestation mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est aussi la composante
ouvrière de 1968
et le climat d'insubordination ouvrière
généralisé que mes 68 a révélé c'est en
effet la spécificité du 68 français car
la répression brutale du mouvement
étudiant avait provoqué une mobilisation
des travailleurs
une journée de grève générale était
organisée par les syndicats
le 13 mai une immense manifestation
avait lieu le drapeau noir en tête mais
le lendemain débordant les appareils les
ouvriers décidaient spontanément de
poursuivre le mouvement c'est la
première grève générale sauvage de
l'histoire
tous les secteurs sont touchés non
seulement les grands groupes publics
mais encore les entreprises privées des
plus grandes au plus petites
les centrales sont arrêtés les cheminées
ne fument plus dans les mines on refuse
de descendre les docks sont désertés
même les secteurs les plus inattendus
entre dans la grève les banques sont
fermées les grands magasins sont occupés
par leur personnel
le ramassage des ordures est suspendu
des banderoles des corps l'entrée des
hôtels de luxe les mariniers
occupent la scène on ne prélève plus
l'impôt les fossoyeurs n'entèrent plus
les os sont en vacances et les péages
sont gratuits
la radio et la télévision réclament la
fin de la censure et les actualités
publiques remplacent la mort de leur
roche par des petits à cerclés il n'y a
pas jusqu'au football qui demande la fin
de l'aliénation et occupent leur
fédération lors des grandes grèves de
1936 on avait compté 2 millions de
grévistes en mai 1968 il y en a au début
6 millions puis au bout de quelques
jours plus de 10 millions dans toute la
France non seulement dans toutes les
grandes villes de France mais dans les
campagnes alors ça il faut surtout pas
l'oublier mais moi j'ai trouvé dans les
archives des des tracteurs qui défoncent
des sous-préfectures on n'a jamais vu ça
on a quoi
c'était incroyable vraiment incroyable
on n'aurait jamais imaginé ça une
semaine avant
et cela donne toute leur justification
aux idées anarchistes
la reine des les gens sont capables de
prendre conscience
l'anarchiste
les gens sont capables s'ils sont
conscients de le vivre de manière
immédiate et spontanéisme spontanément
les gens se transforment en anarchiste
ou en liberté comme s'il avait toujours
été
vrai de côté certains aspects
fondamentaux de l'émancipation le
patriarcat n'est que partiellement
dénoncé les minorités demeurent
invisibles et la question écologique
n'est pas posée mais dans les
occupations l'esprit entier autoritaire
et libertaire se diffusent à tel point
que vers la fin mais on commence à
imaginer la disparition des frontières
du travail et de l'argent et avis
accompagné lorsque au coupable il y
avait des travailleurs qui occupaient
leur entreprise informatique comme il y
avait de nombreux autres lieux de
travail occupés
la direction est venue pour leur
demander que voulez-vous quel est votre
plateforme de revendication rééducation
on ne veut plus travailler on ne veut
plus de cette société
oui d'accord on comprend mais au niveau
des horaires du salaire qu'est-ce que
vous voulez
c'est comme une chape de plomb qui
explosait et les joies de vivre les
exubérances ont repris leurs droits et
quand les exubérances reprennent leurs
droits comme Raoul van eghem l'a subi un
dit bien les gens reprennent envie de
vivre le goût de vivre et le goût des
audaces mais ces audaces ne sont pas du
goût de tous dans l'urgence le chef de
l'État convoque un conseil
extraordinaire la consigne donnée est
répétée du sommet de l'État jusque en
bas résumé l'opinion du Président de la
République c'est la réforme oui la chie
en ligne non
ou des anarchistes convaincus
structurées et organisés sont aux
avant-postes du mouvement que la
réaction commence il y a une forte
présence anarchiste alliance c'est vrai
d'abord il y a une tradition anarchiste
à Lyon qui est ancienne ça c'est une
chose et donc les gens s'inscrivent dans
cette tradition anarchiste les nouveaux
anarchistes les anarchistes de Lyon sont
tous des anarchistes newlook qui ont lu
l'international situationniste et qui
trouve ça absolument formidable
regrouper au sein de l'Hydre de Lerne un
groupe dissident de la Fédération
anarchiste ces libertés New Look sont
nombreuses aussi dans le mouvement du 22
mars lyonnais ils ont occupé leur
facultés et essayer de faire la jonction
avec les ouvriers des grands bastions
que son berliés et la relié à CETA mais
à la différence de Paris le mouvement
est depuis le début resté assez simple
or le 24 mai emmené par les anarchistes
le défilé se heurte à un impressionnant
dispositif policier il se passe à Lyon
une seule nuit de barricades mais c'est
une nuit de barricades qui est devenue
en quelque sorte emblématique de Mai 68
pour toute la France car il se trouve
que au cours de cette nuit des
barricades un commissaire de police est
décédé refluent de la place des Terreaux
sur la presqu'île où ils ont mis en
route les gardes mobiles les
manifestants avaient décidé de marcher
sur la préfecture de police qui se
trouve sur l'autre rive du Rhône mais à
l'entrée du pont Lafayette un barrage
les attend pour forcer le passage dans
la confusion des révolutionnaires
acquisitionnent un camion de chantier et
le lance sur les forces de l'ordre
il est lancé à 5 à l'heure avec un
caillou sur l'accélérateur en première
il avance tout doucement tout doucement
tout doucement et la police a 100 fois
le temps de s'écarter pour laisser
passer le camion la police n'a pas
besoin de s'écarter puisque le camion
des villes lentement et choc contre l'un
des réverbères du pont
mais à ce moment précis le commissaire
de la Croix un commissaire de police et
pris un malaise il est mort parce qu'il
était présent sur les faits la nuit des
barricades il est mort de peur il a fait
une crise cardiaque au moment de
l'arrivée de ce camion mais il n'a pas
été touché par ce camion il a été
acheminé en ambulance ça j'ai trouvé
l'archive en ambulance à l'hôpital
Grange Blanche et il a été soigné à cet
hôpital il était vivant il a parlé avec
les médecins et les infirmiers et puis
au cours du traitement une heure ou deux
après il est décédé au cours du
traitement
voilà donc il n'est pas décédé écrasé
par le camion
et pourtant le lendemain matin au
premier heures du jour le préfet de
police de Lyon prend la parole en direct
à la télévision et donne une autre
version des chaînes et c'est ainsi que
le commissaire prenait la croix père de
trois enfants et fut écrasé entre le
parapet du pont et ce camion
le but est d'être criminel j'ai tout 68
et effectivement du fait que un
commissaire de police est décédé la
réaction s'est emparée de cette
événement pour en faire
le cri de ralliement de la vengeance
une stratégie du choc et fabrique du
consentement au cours des funérailles
nationales du commissaire on répète
alors vu la version policière
le commissaire la croix tentant de
l'arrêter fut écrasé entre le camion et
la rambarde du pont cet événement
souvent négligé de l'histoire de
contribue avec d'autres à faire quand
quelques jours seulement l'opinion
publique se retourne et la situation se
renverse le pouvoir reprend l'avantage
les manifestations sont interdites les
lieux occupés sont évacuées et certaines
figures du mouvement sont incarcérées ou
comme Daniel Cohn-Bendit expulsé
mai 68 a vécu
mais si la révolution libertaire est
manquée grâce à la lutte les
travailleurs obtiennent tout de même de
meilleures conditions de travail et de
vie les lycées et les universités se
démocratisent il a censure dans les
médias reculent ma mortalité
et dans les années qui suivent le
rapport de force né du mouvement permet
de conquérir certains de ses droits que
les anarchistes réclamaient depuis des
décennies comme celui à l'avortement
confirmant dans cela s'il en était le
besoin le vieil adage libertaire selon
lequel aucune de tentative
révolutionnaire n'est jamais verte et
l'Espagne
mai 68 sont effectivement des échecs
mais les gens s'en souviennent comme
d'un moment où il a été possible de
renverser le régime l'adresse humaine et
cette impression perdure
la remise en question des hiérarchies a
été très profonde et chaud
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui rien n'a pu les
passer
[Musique]
stoppez en France le mouvement
insurrectionnel se poursuit dans le
monde
d'une rochu de d'une rival autre des
océans quel que soit les systèmes et les
régimes à la suite de mais la fièvre
s'empare de toutes les grandes capitales
avec comme consigne faire comme en
France
à Bruxelles à Londres Zurich Stockholm
monte et vidéo Tokyo les étudiants
occupent leurs universités créent des
communes et appelle les travailleurs à
les rejoindre
penchant profiter de leur gloire
retrouvée et saisir l'esprit de la
révolte les anarchistes organisant
septembre 1968 à Kara en Italie un
nouveau congrès international
on annonce un grand moment de le
confrontation et de vérification et la
presse venue en ombre doit donner de
l'écho à l'événement
les figures du mouvement montrent
chacune leur tour à la tribune
mais les vieux démontrés les générations
s'opposent et des courants se déchirent
et c'est ainsi qu'au moment où les
organisations anarchistes auraient pu
jouer un rôle dans ce mouvement
révolutionnaire international et le
laisse passer le train de l'histoire
la réaction qui partout au Père
étouffent dans les urnes aux noix dans
le sang les rêves de changement de la
jeunesse à Chicago la marche des
étudiants contre la guerre était écrasée
au Japon on l'excurs je la forteresse
des étudiants révolutionnaires de
l'université totale et le 2 octobre 1968
sur la place des trois cultures au
Mexique le gouvernement fait tirer sur
les étudiants qui s'étaient
pacifiquement rassemblés
il y a plus de 300 morts cet événement
qui restera dans les mémoires comme le
massacre de clatelolko et vient mettre
un terme aux rêves d'impossible
changement pacifique rappelle à de
nombreux révolutionnaires les mots de
Bakounine les révolutions ne sont pas un
jeu d'enfants ni un débat académique ni
une joute littéraire où l'on ne verse
que de l'encre la révolution c'est la
guerre et qui dit guère dit destruction
des hommes et des choses il est sans
doute fâcheux pour l'humanité qu'elle
n'est pas encore inventée à moyen plus
pacifique de progrès mais jusqu'à
présent tout pas nouveau dans l'histoire
n'a été réellement accompli qu'après
avoir reçu le baptême du sang
notre drapeau rouge et noir
notre étoile jaune et noir
[Musique]
notre étoile
jaune
et noir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]